The main asteroid belt between Mars and Jupiter
is home to millions of meteoroids.
But how did these objects form in the first
place?
Astronomers have two ideas.
One thought is that asteroid ancestors, also
known as planetesimals, became large through
gradual accretion, grabbing more and more
material over time,
like a snowball rolling down a hill.
The other idea is that asteroids were made
via gravitational collapse;
that the space dust that makes up the asteroid smashed together almost instantaneously.
Because eons of collisions have broken apart
these original asteroids,
scientists aren’t sure which one of these theories is true,
but they’ve made a big leap toward proving the latter.
Similar asteroids are sorted into groups called
families.
Researchers selected a family of asteroids
known for their low reflectivity in an area
of the belt where there’s a large amount
of brighter asteroids.
Each of these “dark” asteroids were in
a slightly different orbit, but when mapped out,
the asteroids were in a v-shaped formation
Unlike the brighter asteroids nearby, this pattern was more spread out
Not only does this mean that more collisions happened, but
that radiation pressure from sunlight shifted
their orbits gradually over time.
The extent of the spread means
that these dark asteroids have been around longer than their lighter neighbors
the researchers suggest the original dark planetesimals
were probably formed 4 billion years ago,
making this one of the oldest asteroid families in the main belt.
Because the researchers determined that the
original planetesimals were no smaller than
35 kilometers across, they say this is compelling
evidence for gravitational collapse,
because it’s close to the size average needed
for the hypothesis to work.
But for now there’s still a lot of work
to be done before we know the true origin
of our companions in the belt